this episode is brought to you by four
sigmatic which is part of my morning
routine also part of my afternoon
routine routine saves me so there are a
number of ways that i use for sigmatic
in the mornings i regularly start with
their mushroom coffee instead of regular
coffee and it doesn't taste like
mushroom let me explain this first of
all zero sugar zero calories half the
caffeine of regular coffee it's easy on
my stomach tastes amazing and all you
have to do is add hot water i use travel
packets i've been to probably a dozen
countries with various products from
four sigmatic and their mushroom coffee
is top of the list that's number one i
travel with it i recommend it i give it
to my employees i give it to house
guests so if you're one of the sixty
percent of americans or more who drink
coffee daily consider switching it up
this stuff is amazing that's part one
that is the cognitive enhancement side
easy on the system side energizing side
the next is actually their chaga tea
which tastes delicious
it is decaf completely decaf
and some may recognize chaga it is
nicknamed the king of the mushrooms it
is excellent for immune system support
so needless to say i am focused on that
right now myself and so i will often
have that in the afternoons they make
all sorts of different mushroom blends
if you are doing exercise as i am on a
daily basis to keep myself sane
cordyceps excellent for endurance they
have a whole slew of options that you
can check out every single batch is
third party lab tested for heavy metals
allergens all the bad stuff to make sure
that what gets into your hands is what
you want to put in your mouth
and they always offer a 100 percent
money back guarantee so you can try it
risk free why not i've worked out an
exclusive offer with four sigmatic on
their best-selling lions main coffee i
literally have a mug full of it in front
of me right now and this is just for you
my dear podcast listeners receive up to
39 off i don't know how we arrived at 39
but 39 off it's a lot they're best
selling lions main coffee bundles to
claim this deal you must go to four
sigmatic dot com slash tim this offer is
only for you and is not available on
their regular website go to four
sigmatic that's f o u r
f-o-u-r-s-i-g-m-a-t-i-c
dot com
tim to get yourself some awesome and
delicious mushroom coffee full discount
is applied at checkout
this episode is brought to you by eight
sleep my god am i in love with eight
sleep good sleep is the ultimate game
changer more than 30 of americans
struggle with sleep and i'm a member of
that sad group temperature is one of the
main causes of poor sleep and heat has
always been my nemesis i've suffered for
decades tossing and turning throwing
blankets off putting them back on and
repeating ad nauseam but now
i am falling asleep in record time
faster than ever why because i'm using a
simple device called the pod pro cover
by eight sleep it's the easiest and
fastest way to sleep at the perfect
temperature it pairs dynamic cooling and
heating with biometric tracking to offer
the most advanced but most user-friendly
solution on the market i polled all of
you guys on social media about the best
tools for
sleep enhancing sleep and aidsleep was
by far and away the crowd favorite i
mean people were just raving fans of
this so i used it and here we are add
the pod pro cover to your current
mattress and start sleeping as cool as
55 degrees fahrenheit or as hot as 110
degrees fahrenheit it also splits your
bed in half so your partner can choose a
totally different temperature
my girlfriend runs hot all the time she
doesn't need
cooling she loves the heat and we can
have our own bespoke temperatures on
either side which is exactly what we're
doing now for me and for many people the
result eight sleep users fall asleep up
to 32 percent faster reduce sleep
interruptions by up to 40 and get more
restful sleep overall i can personally
attest to this because i track it in all
sorts of ways it's the total solution
for enhanced recovery so you can take on
the next day feeling refreshed and now
my dear listeners that's you guys you
can get 250 off of the pod pro cover
that's a lot simply go to eight sleep
dot com slash tim or use code tim that's
eight all spelled out e-i-g-h-t
sleep dot com slash tim or use coupon
code tim t-i-m eight sleep dot com slash
tim for 250 off your pod pro cover
at this altitude i can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start to
shake can i answer your personal
questions
[Music]
i'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal endoscopy
[Music]
well hello boys and girls ladies and
germs this is tim ferriss welcome to
another episode of the tim ferriss show
where each episode is my job to
interview and deconstruct world-class
performers from all different areas to
tease out the habits and routines or
maybe frameworks decisions approaches
who knows that you can apply to your own
lives my guest today is beau chao bo
last name
s-h-a-o bowshow is a co-founder and the
chairman of evolve a philanthropic
investment firm composed of a foundation
evolv foundation and an impact
investment firm evolve ventures with
initial capital of 100 million from the
shao family evolv aims to support
organizations that relieve inner
suffering and facilitate inner
transformation both story is pretty wild
so let's jump into a little backstory
and we're going to go in reverse
chronological order
prior to evolve beau was a founding
partner of matrix china a leading
technology venture capital firm in china
which manages more than 7 billion and
has funded more than 500 companies 50
plus of which have become unicorns that
means valued at more than 1 billion usd
he is also a serial entrepreneur who has
co-founded five companies that have
either gone public or become leaders in
their respective industries beau was
born in china and was the winner of more
than a dozen national mathematics
competitions during high school
for those who don't know what that means
it is a huge huge deal and a very
significant feat
i'm going to leave the rest of his bio
to our conversation and we will dig in
very very quickly the website for evolve
is evolv vf
as in
venture
fund venture foundation so evolve vf.com
he has no social media we will dig into
why that is
and without further ado please enjoy my
wide-ranging conversation with none
other than bo xiao
bo it is nice to see you again sir and i
wanted to perhaps set the stage
by pulling from one of our very first
conversations we ever had
and it involves ketchup might sound like
a strange place to start for those
people listening but perhaps you could
provide just a bit of context and
that'll be a way we can jump in
i grew up in shanghai china i found my
father was a mass teacher i guess he's
retired now he had always been very
strict with me he had many many good
qualities as a father which i won't go
into here
but one of the things he did not do so
well was he was angry all the time and
often for a certain period of years he
was angry
and also he would
unpredictably
get very very angry and get very scary
so
i think one day maybe when i was maybe
five no actually i know exactly how i
was around 10 years old
he brought ketchup home in a bottle of a
beer bottle i remember it's a green beer
bottle
and we never had ketchup before you know
we grew up poor like everybody else in
china
and i think i stole a taste of it
without his permission
and he flew into a rage
i do not remember whether he hit me or
not
but it was very scary
and i i'm sure i cried and it was it was
a terrible time
and then
a couple of days later
i came home
and i saw him in a good mood
and i think that somehow gave me courage
to ask him again like can i try the
ketchup which actually is surprising
because after that episode i don't
usually i would not have worked up the
courage to do something similar
but in that case i did because he looked
so happy so
he said to me
oh you can't have my my chinese nickname
is xiaobo it's like chubby you can have
as much ketchup as you like
i was shocked
and not only i tried to catch up and he
actually bent down to
to hug me
i remember exactly where that happened
it was in front of the kitchen i have a
mental picture of that location right
now
and i don't recall too much
to be fair i can't say he did not hug me
ever yeah he probably did it left such a
deep imprint in me
of getting this kind of i didn't ask for
a hug and he gave me a hug you know in a
very tricky situation
and that left a very deep imprint on me
then later on
i found out that
i won my first mass competition i think
was in fifth grade is a mass competition
involving all the students in shanghai
and shanghai is like at that time
probably a city of 12 13 million people
and i was like clear number one in that
last competition
and that's why he was in such a good
mood
i think so
could you paint a picture of what por
looks like what it looked like for you
because i remember you mentioned rations
and things like that just so people have
a little more detail
first of all i didn't know i was poor
everybody was poor so i didn't know i
was poor which is actually a good thing
but the way we grew up is you know we
when i was you know four or five years
old we didn't always have
meat on the table
everything was rationed including milk
rice
oil cooking oil
meat certainly
very rarely any kind of uh seafood
i think vegetable probably was not
ration i can't remember and you get
these little tickets you have to carry
to a grocery store in addition to
the money and they were making
i think my father was making maybe
certainly less than ten dollars a month
my mother was also making 10 a month as
well
so the tickets are like food stamps
in a sense but there's a ticket for me
there's a ticket for
cooking oil etc
got it and
you had mentioned your father was a good
teacher and
i'd love for you to pick up there and
also i'd love to hear
how and when poker or
cards may have entered the picture
because we were so proud we didn't have
ways of you know setting up maths these
days if you want to stream math you have
lots of tools to do it but back then we
didn't even have an abacus he initially
started just writing down arithmetic
problems like five plus seven or 15 plus
28 on a piece of paper and asked me to
add them he has to write hundreds of
these equations and i need to solve them
but then he said oh he sort of had one
day had an inspiration actually
initially started with my sister who was
who is three years older than me and
said oh why don't we use a deck of cards
and obviously ace is one and two is two
and then jack is eleven the king is
thirteen etc and you add up the deck of
cards initially i should add up only ten
cards and then to twenty and then to 40
involving 1 to 10 and eventually to 52
involving 1 to 13 times 4. the total sum
i think is 364. and then he would take
one card from the 50 card two cards away
and asked me to add up the rest
and he was set a time limit so i have to
get it right
within a certain time limit
and i think i trained for several years
under this method
and i
actually became so fast that i think i
was able to add up 52 cards under
12 seconds or so
and actually just to be able to you know
show the cards so quickly i was gonna
say i don't even think i could show the
cards in 30 seconds i've developed a
particular way of going through these
cards and i think i was doing basically
more or less four or five calculations a
second and it turns out actually just uh
later on as i understood a bit more
about neurobiology is that actually it
takes about 100 milliseconds for the
brain to recognize an image
to be able to see the card clearly and
take it in
and then process information takes one
tenth of a second already or sometimes
depending one tends to maybe one
sixth of a second
so to be able to add five cards in one
second is it probably at the close to
the limit of human biology i guess
[Laughter]
what else did you
absorb
from your parents and maybe it's worth
also backtracking for a second and
asking the question
what lesson subconsciously or otherwise
did you take away from that experience
with your dad with the rage over the
ketchup and then the have all the
ketchup you want hug
from your dad that seemed to coincide
with winning that math competition
i'm still actually
discovering how these imprints
have affected me you know my experience
is that you know and my understanding is
that
i was so imprintable as a child
all children are very imprintable that i
carried away with certain things with me
and that's not his intention i want to
be clear about that but it's
nevertheless is what i carried away with
and one of the
impressions
that i received
was that my value
comes from my performance
in fact specifically to be almost like
number one that's my value
and if i
am not number one then i'm a person with
no value
and i feel heaviness as i talk about it
because it's such a burden
and it was a creative solution in some
ways because indeed i became number one
in many things when i was growing up
particularly math i ended up winning
first prize
in dozens of national math competitions
in china and i felt safe
that performance enabled me feel safe i
think my impression
is that actually i was treated better
after that my father had less of a rage
he was so proud of me
i felt my life changed for the better
significantly better because of that
performance
and then as i grew up
i needed to
perform well in everything it's not just
mass competitions anymore not just
college or the first job
but this kind of almost compulsion to
perform
start to dominate everything including
driving like i need to be
always on the fastest lane
more importantly perhaps i always need
to plot the most efficient
route to a place i remember when i
initially got my tesla i needed to look
at the tesla maps i need to look at
google maps i need to look at waze
so that
i can see which map provides the best
route then i can look at post mortem and
cl which indeed which one was more
accurate
the next time i would i would use this
map for this route etc etc of course i
gave a lot of pressure to my wife
enormous under pressure to
my children
it's a very one of my deepest patterns
of behavior
you ended up going to harvard at 17 how
does a poor kid in china
end up with harvard on the map i
understand you won these competitions
but how did it end up that you were able
to go
from
where you were in shanghai
to harvard at 17 if i'm getting the age
correct i think i came to the us on my
18th birthday if i remember right this
is largely
thanks to my father he
saw it early that
going to america for higher education
will open up
entirely different world of
opportunities
so
he started working on that very early
and back then
going to america for
phds were relatively known quite a lot
of people go because you get you know
research assistance or teaching
assistance
so that you actually get paid
to to study
but for college there were no such thing
so you needed a full scholarship
the reason it needs to be full is nobody
in china back then could remotely afford
a college education in the u.s remember
you know when in the 1980s
when the china economy initially opened
up
people who got rich first were called
which means
people who have ten thousand rmb
that's considered to be very rich
you can get a special name so like
millionaires or billionaires that we use
ten thousand rmb is a big big deal so
actually even when when we started
applying for colleges we couldn't even
afford the application fees which is
like 35 or 50 dollars we actually get i
need to get waivers of application fees
from these colleges
really thanks to him i applied to 20
also colleges in the us when i was in
junior high school
and got into a bunch of them and a
number of them gave me a full
scholarship including harvard and off i
went
when did you start studying english
chinese middle school and high school
education have always emphasized english
as a part of core curriculum so we did
study english in
middle school and high school now the
teaching quality wasn't very good
because most of those english teachers
never no actually not all of them none
of them have ever been overseas and
their accents are you know atrocious
but you know we would learn grammar and
all those things i i think i was able to
probably read
actually i take it back i don't think my
english was that good but then i get
some cramming school outside of the
regular school
to learn english and that helped me
so the cram school just for people who
who might not know what that is that's
like a an additional night school that
you would go to to strengthen your
abilities in a certain subject
yes that is correct and remember my
english was always
definitely i was very unsure and not
confident about my english until one
summer maybe in somewhere in middle
school
where i spent probably half the summer
listening to a few tapes it was a
textbook called new concept english i
think from the uk
and i listened to those tapes
over and over again until i pretty much
memorized it i could even talk not just
the text of the
the lessons but also including the
copyright everything that the the
speaker was introducing the book and
everything you know oxford cambridge
press or whatever all of those things i
listened to so many times i remember it
was a little recorder it was actually
not a little like probably size of a
laptop kind of a but several times
thicker a recorder with these plastic
buttons and i'll click rewind play
rewind play rewind play probably
thousands of times during the summer
and i basically was able to mimic
the speaker on the tape
and memorized without trying to
most of the things that he was saying
and then after that summer my english
just
ceased to be a problem became something
i became very comfortable with
what prompted you to listen to
those tapes thousands of times was it
the pending trip to the us for college
or was it something else no i don't know
why if this is way before even going to
the us appeared on the road map there's
a part of me that just really wanted to
be excellent i think
and this is actually a very important
learning as i actually in the past few
months you know i'm starting to realize
because
let me explain this is actually
important i have this sort of
pattern of behavior
that require me to be sort of want to be
perfect in every situation which is a
burden
and one of the reasons
that i was unwilling whether it's
consciously or subconsciously to let
that pattern behavior go
is that i'm afraid that if i don't
follow this strict pattern
i will cease to be excellent
all the things that made me great or
successful
will disappear
and
then i become lazy
and all that
and i think subconscious i was holding
on to that pattern
for fear of that happening
but
as i connect however now with i was just
talking about this i actually you know
nobody forced me to do this
and i did it because i i there's an
innate drive
in me
i think to do a good job
by things i touch
and at the more in some ways i get in
touch with that innate drive
but it's not a pathological compulsion
like in certain situations it's
appropriate and certain situation is not
appropriate it's a great tool in my
toolbox it's a great trait of mine
but if i actually have more confidence
this is within me that's my inner
quality then the more willing i'll be
letting this other
pattern
go
does it make sense
yeah it does make sense i think that
if it is your
default
and you are not aware
that you have a toolkit with other tools
and if you don't have that develop
self-awareness
then you're sort of sleepwalking
through
parts of your life with
a hammer looking for nails but as you
develop more
awareness of your capacities and also
the side effects of misapplying
the tool both for yourself and other
people then
you develop different strategies right
and you can also be
easier on
everyone including yourself in certain
places and like you said there are times
when it makes sense to pull out the big
guns
and focus on something
intensely but it doesn't have to be you
know figuring out how to shave 12
seconds off your trip to starbucks by
looking at 17 maps necessarily right you
can even go one step further
that if the reason i had developed this
particular coping mechanism or pattern
behavior perfectionism
is because i have an innate inclination
because people react to trauma i use the
word trauma not just referring not to
just a one-time big event kind of a
trauma like abuse but trauma could
happen over a long period of time of a
repeat exposure to certain stimulus that
does not meet one's need
and i was exposed to a particular
situation repeatedly
but however my sister and i responded to
that same situation differently because
of our different innate inclinations
and so it's not a surprise that i
developed this pattern of perfectionism
that's
always there that i couldn't control
because i had innate inclination that's
good but then it became almost
bastardized or misused to cope with the
situation that was very very difficult
and the situation was the just overall
household dynamic is that the situation
you're referring to
it's difficult for me to talk about a
bit here and we can always cut things
out later parties because it's memory
but also i want to make sure that if my
parents ever hear this they know that i
love them dearly and they've done so
much good for me but there are certain
things that simply what needs were not
met and one of the situations was
my father was angry and very demanding
and very controlling
to the extreme
and also he was physically punishing as
well so
i was scared i was scared
i think to the end of my wits i think
some of this rage becomes at very
unpredictable times
so i think i was constantly vigilant and
constantly making sure i was performing
and also another thing in the family
dynamics was that
there was very little attention paid to
how i feel so the feelings were
for the longest time i treated feelings
like an emotional
evolutionary waste product like an
appendix
you know
rationality and analytics is what i'm
built for and emotions just gets in the
way and it serves no purpose
so
i think for a long time until i was
probably my maybe the first time i met
with my wife i don't think i had
many feelings
i didn't know what they were really
just to speak to that because i think
part of the reason we bonded
and
ended up speaking for as long a time as
we did when we first met is that that's
i think some shared experience that we
have in the sense that
when you think emotions are a liability
you
compartmentalize or dissociate in such a
way
to
focus on the things that you feel you
can
control
and apply like rationality right and
becoming
as vulcan-like as possible but over time
and i'm sure we'll talk more about this
things have a tendency to squeeze out
the corners even if you think you've
put them in a nice tidy little
little box
yeah i would love to come back to
your
chronology just a little bit and we're
going to dip in and out of a lot of
these topics
when you first came to the united states
do you remember what
things or any things that were very
surprising to you whether about the u.s
in general about the students you ran
into anything at all did anything jump
out at you as
incredible unbelievable confusing
there was too many things to count
really i came from a country back then
in 1991
where people didn't even have phones in
their homes most people when i had to
call home
i needed to make sure arrange the time
with my parents over regular mail or
over the previous phone call so they can
go to my neighbor
who had a phone
and they would wait by the phone when i
called
but when i got to the us
i remember i was just you know some i
guess vignettes might be illustrative
was uh that when i landed in los angeles
on my way to boston
i needed to call home to
make sure that they know that i'm okay
and by the way just to it's hard to for
me imagine now that my oldest daughter
is off to college to imagine
a parent sending their kids off to
college
knowing that they may never see him
again
for them going to america it was
it's a
it's it's not just getting on the fight
seriously they might never see me again
the courage they displayed in the
selflessness they displayed was is
breathtaking when i caught home from los
angeles airport
i was using a public phone
which is the first time ever probably
seen a public phone
i remember having putting maybe several
dollars worth of quarters into the phone
but the phone refused to connect
and i put more money in it would still
refuse to connect
so eventually i became frustrated
and i switched to the phone next to it
and that payphone worked i put in a
couple dollars or something like that
and connected and told them i was okay
and
as i was on the phone
a cleaning lady came by was cleaning all
the phones and she puts her
finger into the coin return slot which i
didn't even know existed by the way
until she
she put her finger in
on into the phone that i was previously
using
and she got out a whole handful of
quarters probably you know 10 worth of
quarters
and she was so happy she looked at me
and smiled
and you know it took me several days
maybe weeks
after i arrived in boston
to realize actually those quarters were
mine
i think the the the phone must been full
or something malfunctioning so all the
quarters i put into the previous phone
basically went straight down into the
return slot but i didn't realize it
and it took me several days at least
probably longer to say oh one day oh
that's what happened she was taking my
money
what did that feel like to you
and if you could describe also as you've
continued on your journey what that was
like
i think this is important connective
tissue for
some of the rest of the avenues we'll be
exploring
when i got to harvard my focus was on
grades
i needed to be number one
so i remember taking
as many classes i could the normal
course load it was four courses
how many non-chinese had you met before
you got to the us had you met many
non-chinese
i think i met really spent time with was
one
non-chinese person
and his name was nicholas christoph
as a new york times columnist and now i
think he just announced he's running for
the governor of oregon but back then he
was living in beijing
as a journalist
and he was interviewing for harvard
he was a
an alumnus who was interviewing folks
yes got it
and i think i took the first train ride
alone
to go to from shanghai to beijing to to
meet him to be interviewed
so i think he was the only
non-chinese person that i met
i might have met a cousin who was born
in america who came back to china but as
far as a white person
who was concerned yeah i think he was
the first one
so then you get to
harvard and you're like oh my god
there's so many la wai and then you're
like wait a second i'm la why
i think i was so out of it i was so
unsophisticated that none of these
thoughts much occurred to me i was just
so focused on studying i just needed to
study
you just had blinders on you're like
yeah
people from all over the world whatever
distraction
one of the first classes i need to take
was expose which is a writing class
which supposed to be a hellish
difficult
a writing class for college entrance at
the first freshman
and i did very well i think my first
essay was read to the class which is
pretty amazing because
i never written a english essay before
until that point not counting the
application essays
the first essay got an a
but eventually my whole grade for the
course was a minus
and i was very unhappy about that
i remember calling the professor and
complaining that how he could give me a
a minus
[Laughter]
how dare how dare that professor
and and he was very confused image is
really good and it's amazing that you're
writing so well blah blah blah blah blah
but i said well right well we're not
getting a minus
i was so focused on grades at the time
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show
this episode is brought to you by
athletic greens i get asked all the time
what i would take if i could only take
one supplement the answer is invariably
ag-1 by athletic greens if you're
traveling if you're just busy if you're
not sure if your meals or where they
should be it covers your bases with
approximately 75 vitamins minerals and
whole foods source ingredients you'll be
hard-pressed to find a more
nutrient-dense formula on the market it
has a multivitamin multi-mineral greens
complex probiotics and prebiotics for
gut health and immunity formula
digestive enzymes and adaptogens you get
the idea right now athletic greens is
giving my audience a special offer on
top of their all-in-one formula which is
a free vitamin d supplement and five
free travel packs with your first
subscription purchase many of us are
deficient in vitamin d i found that true
for myself which is usually produced in
our bodies from sun exposure so adding a
vitamin d supplement to your daily
routine is a great option for additional
immune support support your immunity gut
health and energy by visiting
athleticgreens.com
tim you'll receive up to a year's supply
of vitamin d and five free travel packs
with your subscription again that's
athleticgreens.com
tim
i want to flash forward and i'll often
bookend things like this because i want
to
in part
flesh out
the picture in the mind's eye for
listeners of
china because it's very easy to
look at
the other whatever the other is and be
like well all people in afghanistan x
the chinese y the americans
z and i'd like to sort of
humanize a bit also
chinese people because china is
not
as much as people might think so in the
western world it's not uniform top to
bottom east to west there's a lot
that happens in china many differences
regionally and so on but you're helping
so present day
in the last few years you're helping
bring mdma assisted psychotherapy to
china i would like to
hear you
describe why you are doing that and why
you think it's important why it applies
and this will just be a way of also
edging into a couple of different topics
and then we're going to go back to your
bio and begin to talk about bcg in 1999
and consulting projects for the
singaporean government we're going to go
there but first i want to just ask
why
mdma assisted psychotherapy
in china or to china we're trying to
work on it and i'm not sure how much
progress we are making but it's very
worthwhile effort for us
because
in some ways
people everywhere
share
most of the similar aspirations
and regardless of their color
or
social economic status
go through very similar traumas in some
ways as i got to know many of my fellow
countrymen over the years particularly
the successful ones actually
as they share some of the stories about
themselves that they never told other
people
that
we all have so much hurt inside of us
and everywhere and these hurts could be
some could be very easily felt
some of it is deeply buried and maybe
even subconscious
so many people
and i you know say so many of us because
i'm certainly one of them develop
certain views of oneself that we somehow
think that we are something wrong with
us
that we are not worthwhile that we have
no value other than the things we do
and just breathtaking how much suffering
there is and i use the word suffering in
the
buddhist sense even though i'm not a
buddhist
and so
mdma and other psychedelic medicine that
have huge
healing potential that i feel really
passionate about bringing that
to the world helping that and certainly
i'm not the main person doing it i can i
like to contribute where i can to bring
that to the world including china and in
china in particular
china went through
some very tough periods after world war
ii there's a period called the cultural
revolution
and prior to that there's a rightist
movement anti-rightist movement that
lasted more or less for 15 years
that really
traumatized
an entire generation of people
can you speak to what that trauma looked
like because i think a lot of folks
listening will not have
they won't be able to conjure any sort
of images of what happened during either
of those
i could start with something personal
was in my family
my grandparents family were relatively
well to do so when the cultural
revolution came
red guards will come from house to house
to search for all the valuables you have
to give them up
every single thing you have if the red
guards want it
you have to give it and there are
stories of people as i was growing up
heard that you know some people
bury some treasures in the backyard
because they don't want to give it up
and then red guards will come and pour
water on the backyard and when the water
sinks in a particular place they will
dig it up
you know obviously they will confiscate
that and probably either
torture or kill the people who try to
bury it in prison the people who try to
bury it
so it was this incredible terror
that happened to
people
and then there was also this race to
show your purity your ideological purity
toward the sort of fertilitarian what do
you call it proletarian what's the right
proletariat they have proletariat
revolution
so you have to chant the right things
and you have to in every turn
yeah the proletariat the workers of the
working-class people regarded
collectively
yes that's right you have to chant
you have to follow all the dictates
don't chair my mouth
in the middle of the night you might be
forced to get up and you cannot complain
if you complain you are disloyal to go
on the streets at two o'clock in the
morning to
to march and to
to shout slogans at the top of your
lungs
there's a real story that my
my father actually tried to help
somebody somebody who's a good teacher
was
denounced i'd be not being loyal to the
party and he spoke up for this person
and then he got in trouble for it
and later on
much to his dismay and disappointment
anger this person made up stories about
him
instead of being grateful and helping
him
the other victim actually made up
stories about my father to protect
himself
because the more you denounce other
people and tell secrets about other
people the more protected you are you
show your loyalty
so during cultural revolution
many children were forced
to tell on their parents
and that creator can imagine the amount
of distrust that creates amongst
everybody
they're so scared and my father was
put on for a few times because he came
from a rich family and also because i
think he helped this other person
he was put on on a platform in front of
hundreds of people denouncing him
spitting on him
he would wear tall hats that could be
very heavy for hours while standing in
front of
hundreds of people denouncing shouting
things at him
he wasn't you know didn't get the worst
deal they're people who got more or less
lynched
thousands maybe tens of thousands of
people maybe hundreds of thousands of
people
and millions i think was millions of
people were sent to the countryside to
do manual labor to reform their thinking
it was really
this is all from secondhand because i
was too young i was only a few years
something happened before i was born
but other times was i was maybe one or
two years old so this is all through
secondhand
but but there's so many stories and this
is a period of time that is not often
discussed
but
i would say this whole country has ptsd
it's very hard to imagine going through
that i mean war of course can be very
traumatic
in a physical form of course and very
scary
but when a country goes through this
kind of
internal convulsion
where people are betraying each other
left and right every single day
it's hard to imagine the impact on the
psyche
of a generation of people
thank you for sharing all that context i
think this is really
important
on a number of levels i think for
people to gain an appreciation of and i
say people probably referring to those
who haven't had firsthand experience
one film
that may be interesting to folks and
i don't know if you've seen it i'd be
curious to hear if you have but
there is a
chinese filmmaker named i don't know the
tones on his name but jiangi mol
y-i-m-o-u
and
he made a film called
to live
which is uh i guess huaja
that was initially denied theatrical
release in mainland china but later
i believe was made available and it
covers
the working-class experience
through
a number of very difficult periods of
modern chinese history from the chinese
civil war in the late 1940s to the
cultural revolution and jiangimo has a
beautiful cinematography
style it's usually very color saturated
and stars a number of folks who have
appeared in many of his films like gong
li
who i had a crush on when i was in china
in 96 oh my god
but that's also an option for people who
might want to this film to live was made
or released in 1994 so people can can
try to find it
i'd love to come back to your experience
in the us so we flash then to
say
and you tell me if this is the right
place to start maybe there are things
that happen beforehand that are worth
noting but it seems like
you have your first job
sort of real official job bcg where
you're you're giving uh your mandate is
to give advice to these these big
companies and we're paying you guys a
fortune
and
at some point i don't know if it was bcg
but you had a consulting project
for the singaporean government is it
fair to say that was a an important
turning point
and milestone for you yeah that was
definitely a turning point i think i
made a
a few big decisions in my life that all
worked out and there's a general theme
of
getting closer to who i really am
versus what i was made to be by the
environment
but one decision was starting a company
and i was inspired by a
field study that i did with a couple
other students
at the end of my business school
are studying what internet models worked
at the time
and which of those can be successfully
adapted to asia and this is in 1999
really at the height of the internet
boom
in the us
and
what we discovered was that most
business models didn't make a lot of
sense
there was a lot of hype a lot of bubble
but we thought the ebay business model
really is incredible
so
i looked into
whether anybody
was doing that in china
and the answer was no in 1998 so i said
oh okay when i graduate i will go back
to start the
online auction
website in china and
that was a huge step for me because up
to that point
i was this
steady person i was a mass geek and then
even when i got a job it was from one of
the most established and prominent firms
it's all very
understandable it's like a very
steady thing and also i also left my
back door open on my there's a way to
back because i actually got a deferral
in a
phd program in physics
when i initially took my job at bcg so i
had a had a backup
it's always very safe and steady
but going back to china not getting a
green car from the us in 1999
to start a company
whose business model i couldn't even
explain to my parents i think i'm
convinced that they
they do not know what the business is i
don't even sell things i didn't even
sell things i was building a platform
for other people to sell things
i didn't have a store even no no
department's like it's it's
mind-boggling
what that platform really means so that
was a big big step and i didn't know
what the hell i was doing whatsoever
despite business school
so i want to well ask a couple things so
how did your parents respond to this
well to their credit
they didn't say a thing
i was living at home
when i got back to china in 1999
i had an office another in another
apartment really it's not an office and
an apartment building
i couldn't find anybody to work with me
really i didn't know anybody really
other than my high school classmates
because i was out of the country for
what by then eight years
so the only people i knew were my high
school classmates so the only the first
my first recruit was a
high school classmate of mine who was
trading stock at home so he didn't have
much to lose so he joined me
you know i couldn't find
even programmers back then building an
internet website is not a thing it was
not a thing yeah
yeah in 1999 china it was all dialer
modems back then by the way there's some
internet access there's all that modems
my kids don't even know what that
moderns are
these days
and yeah it's the only guy who found two
part-time programmers for you to work
for the shanghai electricity bureau they
never built a website before ever they
were i.t maintenance people but they
knew some microsoft asp programming
language they didn't want to quit their
jobs and so they they would go to their
regular bureau jobs government jobs and
work from 6 pm to like midnight every
night to build the website
and then they'll go back to their
regular jobs good thing the job is not
very demanding so they could sleep
during the day
in the office and at night
they work for us and work for me i guess
so we have these basically four
employees three employees and me then
they built the website
uh after i think two months surprisingly
let's just finish the website of course
as soon as they launched it probably
crashed
so um it was a long but things my
parents didn't see anything like they
just said oh okay like really to my
father's credit particularly
he knew that he didn't know
what he didn't know
and he trusted me to make my own
decisions
do you know this is a leading question
of course but is there any element of
you already having sort of brought
honor and reputation to the family
through
winning the competitions going to
harvard where effectively you had
already passed any tests that you might
need to pass in your father's
from his perspective or or is that do
you think that's not a factor
i think he was incredibly proud of me
for sure winning so many mass
competitions in china was a big deal
when i initially
was thinking of going overseas to study
we even got a call from the shanghai
government saying that oh we wish that i
do not leave before my senior year
because
in senior year i have the chance to
participate potentially in the math
olympiads and win
gold medals or whatnot for the country
and i will bring honor to the shanghai
government and all that so he was very
proud of me from that and of course
going to harvard's big deal as one of
the earliest i think another student
from shanghai and myself got the whole
foreign student thing
directly coming from china started that
was the first year i think after that
every year was two three students
getting full scholarships
so he was very very proud though putting
myself in his shoes
like
imagining my own kid giving all of that
up
even including a green card in the u.s
which is this incredible
valuable you know entertainable thing
most people
view
to go back to china to start something
in the startup
thing entrepreneurship is unheard of in
china more or less in china back back
then
you know if you're an entrepreneur you i
guess you start a food store you don't
start companies really back then so for
them not to say anything to me to
question what not i think it's still a
big deal i really still big deal yeah
yeah i really
really value them for it so let's take a
look into your experience during that
time because it does it does seem pretty
wild
given all of the factors
bcg
can pay well consulting certainly can
pay well
you're coming out of harvard
your parents previously making
10 to 20 dollars a month suddenly you're
in a position to
get a green card to take any number of
jobs that would pay you who knows how
much money i have no idea but you know
fifty thousand a hundred thousand who
knows more maybe
what was going on internally in your
mind
or otherwise that gave you
you're certainly highly rational person
so i don't believe the decision to go to
china to be an entrepreneur was an
impulsive
move that wasn't thought through so how
did you think
through
the pros and cons and risks of doing
that because from the outside looking in
without any explanation it does kind of
look crazy
well i was very rational for sure
actually for a while i was deciding
between going back to bcg versus going
going to work for goldman sachs
and uh where in summer intern during the
middle of my business school yeah both
known for paying more than minimum wage
generally that's right i think i
definitely could have made more than a
hundred thousand dollars a year
at age 25 but
i was preparing even a spreadsheet sort
of listing the pros and cons
and i think one person i met who was a
senior person at bcg in china asked me a
question was like what do you want to do
putting aside all these pros and cons
what do you want to do
and that sort of stumped me actually
because i didn't need what i want i want
it
and all my life frankly
nobody really asked me that question
what i wanted
up until that point
i think
one big decision i made for myself was
to be with my now wife then girlfriend
that was a huge thing for me which we
can go back to
but
in terms of career
i was just
going to through whatever is the most
popular thing was you know bcg when i
graduate from college was the most
popular career choice bcj mckenzie and
got offered from both then after bcu
going to business school was the most
popular choice after two years so i got
an offer from both stanford and harvard
business school that was this clear
choice going to back to china however
was not a popular choice
and i think not as i think about 12
chinese students in the harvard business
school graduating class of my year i
think i was the only person going back
to china that actually a few years later
all
i think 10 of the 12 eventually all went
back to china that's a different story
but that was not popular back then and
starting companies certainly wasn't
popular uh i guess well take it back i
think starting internet companies in
1999 1998 99 might have been popular
choice but i don't think i was driven by
that i think it was driven
because i really saw an opportunity and
i felt that
it's such a good business and it will it
should be created
i think there was this kind of belief
that this is
a business worthwhile to be created and
since nobody else is doing it i should
be doing it no of course i didn't know
that back then several other companies
were preparing to launch so i definitely
wasn't the
only or even the first one to launch
but it felt like this is something that
should happen
if we look at that decision you had this
conversation with a bcg partner in china
who asked you what you really wanted
and you saw this opportunity did you
also have a contingency plan
in the case that it didn't work out oh
yes i did actually i told bcg
their senior partner in china that
i will start the business for a few
months
after a few months the business should
be in good shape then i'll go back to
bcg
we'll have it all figured out in a few
months
i'll check everything out it will be
steady will be autopilot and then i can
go home
[Music]
i have no idea
what he thought about my
i think his name is john wong and what
he thought about what i said at the time
but he was very generous and he said
okay that's okay
and
he agreed to it i think he held my place
for at least a year
so this is really important and i know
i've said that about a number of points
but it's so common for i think
i would usually get to choose you you
were talking about dial up modems you
know i need to stop using the example of
like people on magazine covers because
now the only time you ever see magazines
is in the airport
like it's not really a thing anymore
but the profiles and so on that you read
about entrepreneurs tend to be turned
into these
romanticized action movies and
there's certainly a lot of action but
when someone says
zuckerberg dropped out of college right
people
hear that and they think oh my god he
threw it all away burn the ships bet it
all and it's like actually that's not
that's not what happened because in many
of these schools you have the ability to
defer graduation or come back
over a certain period of time or maybe
at any point in
time
and
it's
i think helpful for would-be
entrepreneurs to hear that oftentimes
the best entrepreneurs do take
calculated risks but they also mitigate
risk right so you had had this
conversation
and you had in a sense a safety net of
sorts so that you could do this
experiment and see what would happen
with the company and i think that it's
it's really helpful to kind of peek
behind the scenes that's a good point so
if we go back to the company at the time
when you were first getting started with
the it guys were sleeping in the office
during their day job and working at
night
what was the name of the company
it's called eachnet
like each and everybody's net
okay
yeah in chinese means interesting
exchanges
interesting exchanges how do you say
that in chinese what was the name
e means exchange chi means interesting
oh fun
yeah yeah yeah got it the sound actually
works the translation works
that's cool so it's it's a
transliteration but you also have the
meaning which by the way anyone
listening when you ask someone
when you if you ever ask a chinese
person to
write my name in chinese part of the
reason it's so hard is you have to think
very carefully about what the characters
mean you can't just
grab the
phonetics and
throw something on paper you have to be
very careful about
what the actual meaning is and you know
i actually don't know if i ever told you
about
when i
first went to china and was studying at
the beijing
what is it in english can you remember
the beijing jingji mauidashi oh yeah
beijing capital university business and
economics
and i had been given my name
my chinese name at princeton which was
fei ting chung and
fei ting
sort of expense in a way is is the
meaning
would be uh like a tip like happy dad
spanish whatever but funny enough you
were saying that your parents would call
you like little little bow right yes
if people use that with me my name meant
tip but so that was problem number one
with my chinese name so faye was for my
last name ferris right and then ting
chung so the t sound was
tim
and they they used chung with yanzapan
because i was always so blunt in class
it was oh i see
tim very honest because i was a pain in
the
ass but the problem with that name or
one of the problems
i'll give two examples of problems when
i got to
china and you're telling people your
name and it's a strange kind of
transliterated foreign name it's not
always clear what the hell you're saying
and so some people thought my name was
feijitang which is airport right so
that was a problem they're like your
name is airport that's strange other
people heard my name as fei ting chang
instead
long also has problems
so
ultimately we change my name to feiyu
and use
but without the
at the bottom it's a pretty um rare
character but anyway so this is just a
long way of saying you have to you have
to think very carefully about how you
name things and yeah by the way the
readers for the listeners who do not
know chinese i would say your chinese is
actually really good your chinese
pronunciation is very good oh thanks man
it's very rusty but i hope to get back
here at some point get back to china
because the china i know
is 1996 china i mean this is like
people's liberation
oh yeah green jackets silk road with
dvds
burners inside jackets
and
bicycles i mean that's the beijing i
know i've got to take you back to china
you will be just shocked your job be on
the floor yeah visit the sci-fi future
so coming back to each net
when did you actually
feel like it was working or you thought
to yourself
oh my god this might actually work like
when was that moment or what were some
of the signs any signs where you're like
okay
maybe this is the thing it's a constant
rollers coaster so there are many
moments
i would say oh this is working but then
the other moment is holy [ __ ] this is
not working it goes up
you know there will be times when we
raise you know initially we raised i
think i'd raise a small angel around
like a few three four hundred k but then
we raised
six point five million dollars i think
in october of 1999
and that was a lot of money back then
and uh yeah
these days a series a of 6.5 million is
really very small but back then it's
actually a fairly substantial amount of
money so definitely i thought oh things
are going well
but then
it turns out five months later i spent
it all
five months
and the thing is i didn't even know i
spent it all
at one point my financial controller
came to say do you know that we have no
more money that we're not going to
payable salary next month is it really i
don't even know like because that's how
little i know about really running a
business it's actually really thinking
back pretty it's pretty embarrassing for
a math champion
that's right that's clearly since we're
not working
and then we need to
to i guess what we call in chinese will
be
which means that you have to tighten
your belts i guess
tighten your belt yeah what did you
spend all that money on
advertising
uh we were one of i think we might be
the old the first internet company in
china to do tv advertising
oh
tv wow
so we had commercials made it was very
exciting and
all that and we got a lot of users and
of course our website crashed all the
time
and at one point i was afraid to go onto
my own website the thinking being that i
might be the last
straw that breaks the cameras
i don't want to add any load to our
servers
that's amazing wow you've got valuable
opportunity to somebody at you who will
find this site useful
alright so quick question the tv
commercial i bet you still remember
parts of that tv commercial what did you
say do you remember any of it in chinese
and then you can explain what it is in
english do you remember any of it
i recall that our logo looked like two
e's facing each other two e's with the
other one being a mirror image of the
other e facing each other
and i ran the tv commercials around sort
of like i remember this logo of two e's
one is orange one is green instead of
talking to each other or playing with
each other or something like that
that i do recall but other what they
actually said to each other i did not
record anymore what was your tagline did
you have a tagline for the company in in
chinese or anything like that yeah
the fun in exchanges
which in english means
the fun in in exchanges
that's good i like that uh all right so
awesome tv commercial you're not even on
your own site because you don't want to
crash the servers
and
you've run out of money and your
controller's like uh bo we have a small
problem we're not gonna be able to make
payroll what happens well we
were able to get everybody in your belt
that's right i think actually got the
team in play together and said okay we
have no more money
and we all need to
take a pay cut so i think we all took
like a 50 pay cut
existing investors
holding it up a few million dollars to
bridge us they were ultimately willing
to do that which i'm very grateful for
and then we went on a fundraising tour
and of course in i think was around
february or march in 2000 the market
crashed
the initial reception was very positive
people without knowing the companies
that we're going to write you a 50
million dollar check but then the market
crashed
and
all of it basically went away
just evaporate i remember credit first
boston was our banker to try to raise
money for us
and we had a lead which shall remain
unnamed uh actually you know i was
willing to write a initial was 50 and
then became 20.
the one day i looked at and i read wall
street journal and on the front page
it says this firm is in trouble
when i read that i said oh that's not
good news they're probably not going to
honor their commitment
so
i thought about what i'm going to say
if the firm calls me to renege on their
verbal commitment or their term sheet i
decided to ask them for 5 million
instead of 20. i said if you give me 5
million
i'll first guild trip them saying how
much trouble they got me in because i
was counting on their money and all that
and that was i make a request i need 5
million not 20. if you give me five
i will raise the rest of the 20.
so lo and behold the next day indeed
this person
called
good thing you saw that newspaper
yeah right and he said he they need to
just withdraw together
and i gave him my prepared spiel
and he said that
he will go back internally to see what
he can do now if i had said that
thank you i understand or this is so if
i didn't make a specific request and
they didn't prepare
this would have been over
yeah instead i made a specific request
that has a chance of being honored
and then i had a very good friend who
went to the boss and tried to reason and
try to cajole
so eventually we did get five million
and then i
begged
many people to put in half a million or
million or whatnot and eventually we
were able to raise 20 million dollars
wow and that's how the company survived
and thrived
did you have
a
backup plan in case the immediate answer
was no did you have say if they say no
to 5 million
i'm going to come back with this other
request
that was plan b
[Laughter]
no there was no backup i think would
have to dissolve i think yeah well i
mean i don't know what the existing
investor would have done but i think it
would be hard pressed for them to
put a lot more money without
profitability insight
i have to ask you bo because i've
noticed this in many of our
conversations do you have an incredibly
broad english
vocabulary like cajole right i mean you
you have a very nuanced
english vocabulary which
is not always the case it's actually
rarely the case i find with a lot of
non-native speakers how did you
accumulate such a vocabulary i guess i
have harvard to thank
[Laughter]
was it harvard because i know a lot of
native speakers i went to princeton with
who do not have your vocabulary
so what happened was uh when i was
applying for
college in the us in you know 1990 when
i was in china
in my junior year high school
i couldn't provide standardized testing
results because sat
was not offered in china
at the time now i think it is
so
i can take the toefl which is the
english test for foreigners which i
passed and did very well in but the
school still wanted some kind of
standardized test
results just like the sats and in fact i
couldn't apply to mit because of it
because mit was not willing to give a
waiver of sat if i got into mit i
probably would have gone to mit given my
orientation at the time
but i was able to convince harvard and
other schools to take the gre
and gre being the graduate record
examination which is for phd programs
and that was offered in china so i took
the gre test
and aced it i think it got 2260 i think
was like the third highest in the
country at that time or something like
that and that helped the application
process but one of the gre i don't know
it still does or not but it has had a
verbal section which is basically
testing your vocabulary
and
i remember it was much harder than sat
verbal sections much much harder yeah
much harder
so i remember getting this huge book of
words that i needed to remember
and i just spent several hours on one or
two months just studying the book
remembering every word
what happens internally or what do you
do when you need to focus for an
extended period of time because you you
have that as a superpower
when you need to say sit down
if you had a new test coming up and
needed to sit down and study something
what does bose studying
look like and that could be things that
you do
or how you prepare
but it could also be your internal
state shift or internal
monologue or self-talk anything
i think it turns out that i learned how
to meditate without knowing that it was
meditation i have a very good ability to
focus
because of that and i think the
meditation i did
was when i tried to add the poker cards
together when i was very young
and to add 50 cards 52 cards together in
12 without 12 seconds
i needed to
get rid of all thought
if i start worrying
if i start trying to consciously add it
it wouldn't work it wouldn't be that
fast
so i need to get myself out of the way
i remember
looking up into the sky or into the
ceiling and just
there's a particular way i blanked my
mind
mine can still see of course but there
is a particular
process of
suppressing thought i guess or getting
out of the egoic kind of self
and with no attachment also another key
thing was no attachment to the result
because the more attached i became the
more agitated and i was thinking that it
wouldn't work and then i failed and it
would actually be times when i was
basically cried because i could do 20 30
times in a row and either they were
wrong
or it took too much time so that it
doesn't count i need to get 10 times
right under the right
limit every day and the limit kept
decreasing as i became more successful
and my father said it that way so
was sometimes at the end of my rope and
i needed to blank my mind
and also not to feel any kind of
attachment to how i do
and that's when i did my best work
and to me that's in some ways just
meditation
and i think i was able to
develop that muscle
without knowing that it's actually
really a form of meditation
yeah it certainly strikes me as
meditation and i think a lot of
athletes also enter meditative states
without calling it
meditation
thank you for answering that question
i've actually always wondered that about
you
so if we come back to
each net how'd that turn out just so
people kind of know how the movie ends
in a sense
we can't do a whole session on this but
i want to be very short about it but you
know it's basically it became successful
became the largest e-commerce company in
china
we sold it to ebay for price i couldn't
say no to
in 2003
and i
retired after that and unfortunately i
was actually i was planning to run it
but a family tragedy prevented me from
doing it i needed to be with my wife to
support her so end up not running the
firm
a couple months after i sold it
and then
ebay did not do well i still feel sad
about it because it was my baby and for
many reasons a multinational company
like ebay couldn't do well in china
so
we went from 80 plus percent market
share in e-commerce down to
5 in a matter of a few
few years
jack ma at the time
was in the b2b business e-commerce but
he launched the
e-commerce b2c c2c e-commerce business
right around the time when i sold my
company
and the company is called taobao the new
company started called taobao which
became the biggest e-commerce player in
china after about 10 years or so
while ebay really struggled despite
having a huge head start
people say this the rest is history
you mentioned
your wife and you mentioned also earlier
in the conversation
how important
it sounded like meeting her and
committing to that relationship was
could you expand on that
especially because you also confessed
earlier that you viewed
emotions as
distractions
so
i'd love for you to say a bit more about
all of that
i think i met her and i just simply fell
in love with her head over heels
a truck hit me and
i didn't even know what happened where
did you mate
i was in business school and she was in
the kennedy school of government
at harvard
so she was the last year last few months
of her time there
and i was doing my first year business
school
and i fell in love
became very irrational i started just
basic thing i believe that
she is meant to be with me and i meant
to be with her and no fear no worry
i went all out
and
the biggest mystery in some ways is
that she loves me back she loved me and
loves me back
even though i was very flawed at the
time
but i guess in front of her
i was emotional i was
extremely passionate
i was considerate
i let all the things i suppressed
i think
show up
in a way that was not conscious it was
out of my control and
without her i don't think i would be the
person that i'm today
so it's not only i have a lag companion
and my best friend
but
also that
you know being with her enabled me to
blossom
whatever that was hidden deep and buried
blossomed
now
to be clear
i only
was that way with her for the longest
time
i was still the same cold
unemotional analytical
judgmental me
with everybody else
for many years after that
so there will be you know very
incongruent
jackal and hide kind of uh
scenarios where i will be just lecturing
my employees
in a very kind of analytical and
judgmental way that my phone would ring
i'll pick up i became like a little
kitten
talking to her in small voices i love
you and i miss you blah blah blah
and i went back straight to the old
straight faced robot that i was many
people have commented
so you you retire
well how old were you when you
retired and i'm gonna put that in
quotation marks i was 29 years old
i was surprised actually because
after the first few months of first
really first week of
ecstasy i was famous on tv all the time
and everything
life was the same as before
funny how that happens yeah
and it was a disorienting because
i think i
built a picture like most people
probably do that somehow you sort of
when you reach that level your life will
become different
in some ways we are i wasn't even sure
what i was searching for
but whatever i was searching for i felt
like well if you get that kind of
success whatever you search for you
would have found it
but actually it didn't happen
i was still the same old me
and very little changed
we may just have to have a round two at
some point and obviously we talk a lot
separately so maybe we can figure that
out but i know that we have let's just
call it how much more time do you have
bo like 20 minutes 30 minutes 30 minutes
or so
yeah okay so we have another 30 minutes
and we may dig into this separately you
did you ended up doing many things after
that your founding partner of matrix
china which manages more than seven
billion dollars and has funded more than
500 companies 50 plus of which become
unicorns there's more to the resume
obviously and you continue to be a
hard charging in a lot of ways yeah and
the resume is not the most important
part about me
which i want to right
so
so this is this well this is the segway
which is
the way we met was in part
around the discussion of
inner journey
and
turning the eye and attention inward
right we didn't meet at a business
networking event we weren't doing a
joint venture together we met in a very
personal context
how did that start for you how did that
process and i know process is a broad
term but
when did that become a priority and how
did it become a priority for you
first i would say that i had no interest
in any kind of inner work for a long
long time in fact i would look down on
people who go to retreats or meditations
whatnot and say what the hell are these
people doing they have better things to
do in life
i was sort of
i found almost disgusting despicable
back then actually
so i had no interest but
life i think has a way of
if one pays attention i guess
to
send little reminders
so the first reminder i got was hey you
know i was still the same me with
some of the same kind of patterns of
behavior same level of happiness and joy
that i had before this big success
and looking back i realized that
compared to the life i have today
the life back then was more of a black
white television and today is more
colorful television
it's hard to describe the difference
if i only watched
black and white television all my life
the reason i use this example was
because i grew up with a nine inch
black and white television which felt
totally fine
for all my life
and without having seen a 80 inch you
know color television the nine inch
black and white look completely adequate
and comfortable
and i think that's where i was
back then
my life didn't have a lot of color
didn't have joy i never cried really and
never laughed never smiled really i
never even felt lonely interesting i
felt alone but not lonely
but i think some of these things showed
up a little bit like oh i've sort of
started wondering what am i missing
there's a little little little things i
think but very small
on that alone i don't think i would have
embarked on a journey
another reminder was how different my
life was with jenny my wife
versus with other people and also i see
how she behaves
with other people in a way that's sort
of beyond my comprehension i remember
like one time she was we were having
dinner with a friend
and
the friend started talking about how he
lost his father
and my wife just stood up and went to
hugging
and
i was dumbfunded
it never would occur to me to do it
she's telling a story i'm listening but
i was not in touch with the emotional
content the story
my wife clearly was and she is one of
the most empathetic person alive that i
know
so some part of me started wondering
what's going on what am i missing and
also i noticed that i could work with
people for a decade and not become
friends with them but she would then go
to dinner with their significant other
the four of us will go to dinner or
lunch and then she becomes friends with
them
but not me
[Laughter]
even though i've known them for 10 years
and she knows them for like one day
so that sort of started sound like you
know am i missing something is
friendship something i value
because up until a few years ago i
didn't consider myself as having friends
but i always told myself i don't need
friends
i want to ask actually just to follow up
there why did you not consider yourself
to have friends is it because you viewed
getting close to people as
having
little upside and a lot of potential
downside why did you see things that way
it was not a rational decision i think
deep down if i were to answer honestly
is because
i think i don't deserve a friend and
um
i think i thought and there's still a
part of me probably still thinks that
there's something wrong with me
that i don't deserve any friends
that nobody would really take an
interest in my feelings and in what i
have to say
unless what i have to say is useful
so when i'm in a position i'm a board
member investor
or somebody who could educate or
whatever
or help
then i feel comfortable like this
relationship has substance
but if it's simply a friendship
a part of me doesn't understand it
like it doesn't feel that why would you
or other people
take an interest in
the inside of me
and i didn't have that trust
uh of course has to do this has a lot to
do with
how i was brought up and i'm still in
the process of
understanding and feeling it fully
but i've told myself for the longest
time i don't need any friends at least
that's the conscious thought
the deeper down you know realization
happened much more slowly
and i think it's still happening as we
speak it's a continuous journey of
discovery
and being free
from those patterns i developed so
that's the second thing that in terms of
friendship and relations with other
people i see myself with jenny in
different ways i see jenny with other
people in a different way that's not
gotten me thinking a little bit
is okay if i continue on this right
absolutely of course right and then and
the third which i think is probably the
biggest one that i couldn't avoid
looking at
was being a father
i was a terrible father you know for a
while on
the chinese twitter weibo i was a it was
very reasonably popular and a lot of
people followed me
and my model i guess whatever i wrote
right under my name was a perfect
husband but a so-so father
and i think i was giving myself too much
credit i don't think i was a social
father i think i was a terrible father
looking back i didn't know how to be one
i knew how to be a teacher
i knew how to be a disciplinary but i
didn't know how to be a father the way i
understand it now
and i didn't know how to spend time with
them i did not know how to give them
love and attention
i didn't know how to
give them support when they needed
emotional support in particular when
they needed
and i also just
did not enjoy being a father i remember
and my wife will remind me to go spend
time with my kids once it's eight
o'clock at night or something like that
before they go to bed before they went
to bed and my thought the time was why
should i and i felt some kind of
resentment
being called to do my job
it was really funny thinking back but
back then i really didn't enjoy it
and that got me thinking a little bit
hey there's something missing here
that you know people talk about being a
father being enjoyable but i really
didn't enjoy it
and also i know that i knew
that i was doing something wrong because
i was
repeating
some of the mistakes that my father made
that was sort of shocking
because
you would imagine that you would never
do what was done to you that he didn't
like
but i was repeating the same thing and
if my wife didn't stop me
i would have been worse far worse so one
of the things that my father for example
did to me is if he got really angry
he would threaten to throw me out of the
home
and i
did that to my son
and that was very traumatic for him he
still remembers it today
even for like two seconds closing the
door on him
it was so bad but i didn't know what
else to do that was all i knew when i
got desperate as a father when something
happens outside of my control i got
desperate so i guess i resorted to what
worked because
from a short-term perspective
what my father did to me worked
i became obedient
thank you for sharing beau i'm really
glad that we're having this conversation
i think it's going to be
meaningful to a lot of people and
i'd love to
hear
as you began
observing these behaviors as perhaps
jenny called things to your attention
and you decided to
try to
change or at least become more aware
what are some of the things that you
found helpful what are some of the tools
or modalities that end up being helpful
because i would imagine
in the beginning certainly i had this
experience myself
it's hard to know where to begin right
and
[Applause]
it's kind of like a chimpanzee with a
mirror or something like you're looking
behind the mirror you're like am i
supposed to see something over here am i
supposed to see something over there
and i would just love to hear because i
know that you have tested many many many
different things
what are some of
say the tools modalities or otherwise
that you have found to be personally
helpful
i definitely tried many different things
i in some ways i'm i like you tim that i
when i get on something i really that's
important then i would want to get to
the bottom of it i want to learn the
best or from the best first of all i
would say that there are three
components to
being a good parent that i've learned
and these are
not necessarily they might be orthogonal
each other meaning they're you know
being good at one component doesn't mean
that they're going to be good at the
second component
so the three components in my view
is one is
understanding
what's going on inside of our children's
heads
and what's going on in their biology in
that psychology
and the amazing thing is we are
children are so different from us we
assume that
they should have executive control of
their body or of their mind or their
actions
but the reality is
for example for a boy their prefrontal
cortex doesn't fully develop until
they're in their 20s
so when they are 12
expecting them to behave in a
disciplined way
is simply not right
so understanding what's going on inside
of them
is hugely hugely important
from a developmental perspective you
mean right from a developmental
perspective both from a physical
neurobiology as well from a
psychological development perspective
and there's huge amount of science out
there that unfortunately
hasn't been made available and
accessible
to parents which is one of the things
one of our companies is working on
and the second
is
as parents
why do we get triggered why did i get
triggered in certain ways
my reactive patterns which were usually
formed very early on in my own childhood
maybe my only insecurity gets reflected
in certain things and then that's why we
got triggered
so for example if a parent always wished
they went to the best schools and they
would be feeding down on themselves but
not having gone to the best schools
they're probably going to be more
demanding of the child
and if the child has bad grades they
probably tend to be more triggered
so there's all sorts of things we need
to understand about our own self and our
own childhood
that would enable us to be a better
parent and so in some ways i went into a
lot of these workshops
thinking that i just need to learn a
tool or trick or some kind of way like
positive discipline or whatever it is to
be a better parent and to a certain
extent those tools and modalities help
but foundational wise
i needed to be become a better person
quote unquote in some ways to be a
better parent
and that has to do everything to do with
our inner journey as an independent
person and has nothing to do with us
being a parent actually this is that's
something that it's really
really foundational
and then the third is
what's in the relational field
between a parent and a child
and becoming aware of that relational
field any moment in time
is really critical because when that
relational field is not right
no amount of teaching on the rational
side an analytical side will help
because
the kid's brain is underdeveloped so
when they don't feel safe and connected
they can't listen
when a typical parent sees a child
children not listening maybe their
reaction is try to say things more
clearly
you know repeat things it doesn't really
help
and what's needed is for the children to
feel safe and connected
and then they will listen a hundred
times better
so these three components understanding
that the children inside of them
understanding ourselves understanding
the relational field for me that's the
foundation then on top of the foundation
there are lots of tools that's actually
very useful
i find that to be so important
it's shocking to me that
now looking back that
being a parent is probably the most
important job
in one's life
there's nothing more important
it's probably the most difficult job
and we are least prepared for
in our lives we go to school for
teaching math we go to
get driving lessons to get a driver's
license so we can drive
but to be a parent
there's practically no preparation so if
we look at those three foundational
pillars and i think it is really
it's a really good reminder to sort of
look at
the first principles
uh at least as you've arrived at them as
these pillars
so you don't get lost in a sea of
tactics without any
elemental
discipline about how you approach them
right because you can just end up with
this frankenstein's monster of
approaches that doesn't really have any
focus to it
i know that for instance you've explored
non-violent communication i know you've
explored the work so testing beliefs
that you have in certain ways people can
find more on that if they look up the
work and byron katie what are other
books or resources or tools that you
have found
particularly effective for you
in
in helping any of the pillars that you
described any of those three
yeah um well we're working on it
right and we when i see we that means we
are starting i've started a company
three four years ago that will have done
now
really three years of research and
development
trying to collect
the best parenting tools the best
research around child psychology and
development
into something that's accessible and
easy and customized
for parents to understand now that's
ongoing and we have a product but i
think we'll get better in the next
couple of months when we launched
the full version
but one of the things i find and
the reason taking so long is i feel that
there are so many different kinds of
kids
and the parenting challenges can be very
different and then certain ways of
parenting works for certain kids in
certain situations
and there's no one-size-fit-all
so
it's really important to collect all the
tools out there and develop a framework
a knowledge graph
so that the right tools and modalities
and tricks can be recommended to the
right
children the right parents the right
situation
for myself as we work on this one
particular thing that has worked for me
is a something called hand in hand
parenting started by this lady patty
wiffler and there's a website containing
i think you search for hand-in-hand
parenting i find their tools to be very
useful for me it has a particular
emphasis on the relationship between
children and parents because that's
that's a particular emphasis
but i'm not sure they wouldn't
necessarily help everybody but i think
they can help a lot of people
so
i think there are other ones i talk
about you know i don't want to mention
that because i don't know them as well
but i think
in the next couple of months our
app should be ready for prime time and
then um then i think uh i'm hoping that
will help a lot of people
so hand-in-hand parenting
i believe you have also
uh correct me if i'm wrong spent some
time
with the
15 commitments of conscious leadership
but a lot of those commitments
you know i've had jim detmer and diana
chapman on the podcast apply to personal
relationships not just leadership and
this is actually something my girlfriend
and i are spending a good amount of time
on right now is
trying to make
implicit agreements which really aren't
agreements they're assumptions
right
implicit assumptions
explicit commitments so that there's
cleaner understanding less
misunderstanding
etc
we can go in a number of different
directions and i know that you're doing
certainly a lot with evolve both on the
foundation side and on the evolve
ventures impact investing side
people can find both
at evolve
that's v is in victor f is in frank so
evolv vf.com
i would like to ask you because i know
that you have
supported research and
have developed quite a bit of
familiarity with the field
what do you think is missing right now
from
the discussion around psychedelics or
therapeutics related to psychedelics
at the moment
i think psychedelics is a
one of the most powerful tools that we
are given
both for healing of trauma
as well as opening ourselves up to
a certain aspect of reality
that has profound love and unity
and safety that's inherent to us into
reality that we normally do not see
and those experiences simply just can be
profound
for me
these experiences
are the starting point
rather than the end points of one's
personal journey
i think they play an incredible role to
motivate people it's almost like here
let me take you on a helicopter tour of
the terrain terrain so you can see what
the big picture is you can see
what the destination looks like but then
the helicopter will land you back more
or less where you started but then you
need to do the personal work so that you
could experience
that a one-time insight more regularly
in life
and also to
that's one and then also to apply it
in one's life it's really difficult i
think spiritual experiences tend to be
overvalued oh i had this incredible
breakthrough i saw whatever god the
buddha or guaying or this incredible
vista of reality
but those if these are so clear and our
culture values these kind of milestones
or things you can talk about so strongly
so highly
that the hard work almost
you know there's this kind of myth of
medicine doing us doing the work for us
which is that's almost its model of
western medicine it takes medicine cures
you and psychedelics sort of can fit
into that center kind of conversation or
framework
but for me it's an incredibly maybe the
most important tool we have
for healing and for opening up
but
then one needs to do the hard work to
integrate those experiences
into our daily lives as a father
as a wife as a spouse as a friend as a
ceo as an investor as an executive
you know as an employee all of those
things
and we have so many patterns of behavior
that's deeply ingrained in us
over our childhood and growing up
that
one or two or ten
one-time experiences do not erase them
so
a teacher might talk about waking up and
waking down
and waking up is actually not not easy
but it's easier than waking down and we
say waking down means integrating the
waking up experience which you see
into them back into our body
back into our daily lives and work
and practice it
and then overcome the patterns
and that's the hard work
that maybe do not get much attention i
think
yeah it's easier to
spin a colorful story about the waking
up and it's very
understandable
and it's
compelling
and
it's often fleeting
if we
sort of return back to
all the invisible scripts that
on some levels
run each and every one of us like you
said right it's very easy to step off of
the helicopter and just turn around away
from the train you just surveyed and
walk back to where you were
that's right if anything sometimes can
even add to your ego oh i had this
experience i'm enlightened now right for
certain personalities having some of
these experiences actually could be
negative yeah this is true
it's uh
perhaps surprisingly common how
messiah complex
is
and it's good to be cogsin of now if if
people go to
the evolve vf.com website they can see
on the for-profit side they can see your
investments which which i think is
actually
it's a it's a fascinating read people
can look at the investments on the
for-profit side they can look at the
grants on the
foundation side uh certainly learn more
about
what evolve does what evolv doesn't do
the leadership team
is there anything else that you would
like to
say or share about
evolve or any requests you'd like to
make of the audience or
suggestions or anything really that
you'd like to
add to the conversation
i guess i would say one thing which is
i think i'm coming from a rational point
of view going back to rational okay
and what i find is
we spend a lot of time optimizing our
lives particularly our work finding the
right job negotiating packages
you know we think about doing you know
if we assign a task and work we prepare
a lot for it we spend hours and days and
weeks on working on particular things if
we need to learn a skill excel or
whatever it is we spend a lot of time
learning it
however when it comes to internal work
whether it's to understand ourselves
or understanding our self as parents
parenting skills
finding a meditation teacher all these
things what i find is most people don't
spend nearly as much time finding the
right teacher
finding the right material
it's almost like this kind of
latch onto the first one if it works
great if not i give up on it or what not
it's not the approach one normally takes
in other work but for some reason when
it comes to inner work
there's a bit of a almost casualness
maybe because they don't know there are
better resources out there like so one
thing that i would encourage everybody
to do
is when it comes to inner work whether
it's meditation or trying to become a
better parent or why not really spend
the time at least as much time
as what
you spend on doing external work
yeah it's very good advice it's really
really good advice it's so easy to
become attached
to the first teacher you find in a given
discipline with respect to inner work
which is very understandable right
because you you are sort of
on some level shown aside of yourself or
a side of reality with or without any
type of pharmacological intervention
that is so
unusual
perhaps so compelling
so
beneficial
that
you can attribute that experience and
the value of that experience to the
person who helped facilitate it right
and sometimes it's well-founded but
sometimes it's misplaced and you can
become attached to
an external agent who is acting upon you
which
can be disabling in a way yeah
one more thing tim if i can say
absolutely
is that we started this conversation i
think talking about i find people who
are dedicated in a work like despicable
or discussed or whatnot right and it's
so funny that my views are so different
now
and for a long time i didn't want to
commit myself and for me inner work has
always been
kind of afterthought it can fit into my
schedule my calendar i would do it maybe
once a quarter once a month or something
like that it was never my priority
and
at one point i think maybe three four
years ago
i said to myself you know what for the
next quarter three months
i'm going to place
as a priority my inner work
whether it's therapy work or
or different experiences why not i say
that's finding the right teacher we're
not going to retreats that's my priority
but only for three months because i
wasn't ready and willing to commit too
much
and
once i made however even that temporary
commitment
my progress changed
so if there's one thing i can say one
more thing i can say just it's around
that is
giving yourself the space to make a
commitment at least a temporary
commitment see what happens you say well
this is only four months i'm going to do
this regularly or what not
and place as a priority on top of
everything else i do and see what
happens
excellent advice
bo it is so nice
to see you and
hear your
voice my friend it's uh it's nice to
reconnect
you know i want to say
like
yeah
which by the way folks if you've ever
wondered where long time no c comes from
it comes from chinese
and
uh people can learn more about evolve i
recommend people check it out evolve
vf.com
and
i love that
in your bio
there is
no social media
and
that's that's a rarity you're one of i
guess two guests are you active at all
on social media or is is that something
you have deliberately removed
i deliberately removed myself from weibo
like
10 years ago or something like that when
i noticed that i was posting to please
other people it became something that
added to my ego and then start to grab
me
and i start tracking how many people
reply how many people forwarded how many
people applauded
and it was not source of happiness
good for you good for you man
so good that is uh
that is inspiring i may need to i may
need to pursue that myself
and uh is there anything else you would
like to say before we wrap up this
conversation one company i didn't
mention this you know this parenting
thing which i thought was what wasn't
quite ready yet it's called parent lab
lab as a laboratory i hope that company
will help a lot of people and in the
next month or two depending on what this
podcast gets out there hopefully
people find it useful
wonderful and i will also
for everyone listening provide show
notes for this episode so we'll have
links to everything we've discussed and
if that is live we'll have a link to
that
and you can go to tim dot blog podcast
to find all episodes but you can go to
tim.log slash bow b o we'll create a
short link and that will forward
directly to the
links and resources and so on from this
particular episode
well bo thank you so much for carving
out the time today
it's my pleasure that was fun thank you
super fun and to everybody listening
be safe experiment often be easier on
yourself than you think you should be
at least at times
give exception and
be merciful with yourself
and
thanks for tuning in
hey guys this is tim again just one more
thing before you take off and that is
five bullet friday would you enjoy
getting a short email from me every
friday that provides a little fun before
the weekend between one and a half and
two million people subscribe to my free
newsletter my super short newsletter
called five bullet friday easy to sign
up easy to cancel it is basically a half
page that i send out every friday to
share the coolest things i've found or
discovered or have started exploring
over that week it's kind of like my
diary of cool things it often includes
articles i'm reading books i'm reading
albums perhaps gadgets gizmos all sorts
of tech tricks and so on that gets sent
to me by my friends including a lot of
podcasts guests and these strange
esoteric things end up in my field and
then i test them and then i share them
with you so if that sounds fun again
it's very short a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend something to think about
if you'd like to try it out just go to
tim dot blog friday type that into your
browser tim dot blog slash friday drop
in your email and you'll get the very
next one thanks for listening
this episode is brought to you by eight
sleep my god am i in love with eight
sleep good sleep is the ultimate game
changer more than 30 of americans
struggle with sleep and i'm a member of
that sad group temperature is one of the
main causes of poor sleep and heat has
always been my nemesis i've suffered for
decades tossing and turning throwing
blankets off putting them back on and
repeating ad nauseam but now
i am falling asleep in record time
faster than ever why because i'm using a
simple device
called the pod pro cover by eight sleep
it's the easiest and fastest way to
sleep at the perfect temperature it
pairs dynamic cooling and heating with
biometric tracking to offer the most
advanced but most user-friendly solution
on the market i polled all of you guys
on social media about the best tools
for sleep enhancing sleep and
ate sleep was by far and away the crowd
favorite i mean people were just raving
fans of this so i used it and here we
are add the pod pro cover to your
current mattress and start sleeping as
cool as 55 degrees fahrenheit or as hot
as 110 degrees fahrenheit it also splits
your bed in half so your partner can
choose a totally different temperature
my girlfriend runs hot all the time she
doesn't need cooling she loves the heat
and we can have our own bespoke
temperatures on either side which is
exactly what we're doing now for me and
for many people the result eight sleep
users fall asleep up to 32 faster reduce
sleep interruptions by up to 40 and get
more restful sleep overall i can
personally attest to this because i
track it in all sorts of ways it's the
total solution for enhanced recovery so
you can take on the next day feeling
refreshed and now my dear listeners
that's you guys you can get 250 off of
the pod pro cover that's a lie simply go
to eight sleep dot com slash tim or use
code tim that's eight all spelled out
e-i-g-h-t sleep dot com slash tim or use
coupon code tim t-i-f eight-sleep dot
com slash tim for 250 off your pod pro
cover
this episode is brought to you by four
sigmatic which is part of my morning
routine also part of my afternoon
routine routine saves me so there are a
number of ways that i use four sigmatic
in the mornings i regularly start with
their mushroom coffee instead of regular
coffee and it doesn't taste like
mushroom let me explain this first of
all zero sugar zero calories half the
caffeine of regular coffee it's easy on
my stomach tastes amazing and all you
have to do
is add hot water i use travel packets
i've been to probably a dozen countries
with various products from four sigmatic
and their mushroom coffee is top of the
list that's number one i travel with it
i recommend it i give it to my employees
i give it to house guests so if you're
one of the 60
of americans or more who drink coffee
daily consider switching it up this
stuff is amazing that's part one
that is the cognitive enhancement side
easy on the system side energizing side
the next is actually their chaga tea
which tastes delicious
it is decaf completely decaf
and some may recognize chaga it is
nicknamed the king of the mushrooms it
is excellent for immune system support
so needless to say i am focused on that
right now myself and so i will often
have that in the afternoons they make
all sorts of different mushroom blends
if you are doing exercise as i am on a
daily basis to keep myself sane
cordyceps excellent for endurance they
have a whole slew of options that you
can check out every single batch is
third party lab tested for heavy metals
allergens all the bad stuff to make sure
that what gets into your hands is what
you want to put in your mouth
and they always offer a 100 money back
guarantee so you can try it risk-free
why not i've worked out an exclusive
offer with four sigmatic on their
best-selling lions main coffee i
literally have a mug full of it in front
of me right now and this is just for you
my dear podcast listeners receive up to
39 off i don't know how we arrived at 39
but 39 off it's a lot their best selling
lions main coffee bundles to claim this
deal you must go to 4sigmatic.com
tim this offer is only for you and is
not available on their regular website
go to four sigmatic that's
f-o-u-r-s-i-g-m-a-t-i-c
dot com slash tim to get yourself some
awesome and delicious mushroom coffee
full discount is applied at checkout
[Applause]